can we get it quiet alright ready to go
guys really we need you it like a - like
it comes out about at Amy Schumer is a
lady in charge and camp she make your
job a lot easier
yes she definitely I'm so crazy about
this woman we sat down we got right to
business talking about her exes her gal
pal Jayla and you know how Amy's got
that famous lower back tattoo oh yeah
well I thought we could do a little
bonding over some ink you have a great
lower back area that is very nice are
you Emily tan Ari
I swim outside a lot the robot that was
supposed to say everyday I'm hustling
but let's see if it's ready okay um yeah
great it's perfect
it says Vijay I'm hustling some of it
didn't come up Amy loved it so much she
instagrammed it out you were 5 million
followers oh that's awesome
I'm definitely the author of the girl
with the lower back tattoo is going
strong with boyfriend Ben Hanish she in
the custom furniture designer met on a
dating app how he's been different from
some of the guys in your path he's
totally different I usually would go for
narcissists and he's not a narcissist
and he's just very supportive and loving
and and I think we're just really proud
of each other in the book you recount
some of your past relationships did you
reach out to them give him a heads up no
no I changed their names the guys in the
chapters that are most difficult I was
in an abusive relationship
and the way I lost my virginity I did
not reach out to this I'm not I'm not in
constant contact with those guys if you
can believe it or not Amy's kept
journals since she was a kid and some of
the provocative stories from her book
are from those early writings it's a
book of essays of
stories from my life that are
humiliating and funny and painful and
happy you know it's just what's happened
to me in 35 years
Amy you like 30 thank you I know but I
am 35 a high praise from Meryl Streep
this past weekend she was as it required
a movie I should put you come on it was
reaction to that high street playing
Meryl Streep and a biopic Amy Schumer of
course she said it's so fast now I know
like I just screamed it was just it's
funny that people are is it happening
I'm like no she's alive thank God
Amy's doing it all she's an author movie
and TV star comedienne and BFFs with JLo
Jennifer Lawrence movie update on that
when is her bday yesterday yeah send her
yeah we're just humbled here what's your
sunburn I just caught I sent her a rude
text but I did call her I called her and
I talked about myself
I'm realizing I talked about myself and
then at the end she went thanks for
calling me on my birthday and I went oh
yeah but uh we were just peeking into
her room for a director and just putting
training it on our calendars we're
really excited about it